for a week now thousands have come out
into the square in Tripoli to join the
chorus of voices across the country
calling for their government to go as
all eyes were on Beirut a few nights ago
this video posted online went viral
dance music played to a jubilant crowd
many first thought this was Beirut when
it was actually here in Tripoli the city
many see is far more conservative
I didn't plan for this I didn't plan for
this I was like all the people I was
going to like all the people we met up
with a man behind the music he says he
played it spontaneously didn't expect
this kind of reaction all the people
they all loved each other
Sydney there's the Messi hey Christian
everything everything everyone everyone
is here because there is no one on top
of them the protests have mobilized the
youth here a leaderless grassroots
movement that has inspired many it was
like a domino effect among the youth in
Tripoli Sally says the protests have
given her renewed hope I asked her
whether she thinks there are challenges
ahead it's gonna be difficult we are
scared and we are aware that we are
going to a bit of a chaotic period after
this but when you're aware it means
you're ready and when you're ready if
this is the first step of succeeding
you're when you're scared you either do
two things you either withdraw or this
gives you perseverance to continue
especially when you got strong out of
many disappointments tripoli is
traditionally a support base for the
prime minister Saad Hariri
but the Sunni majority city has been
neglected it has some of the poorest
areas in the country we are defending
the rights of our children in the rights
of all citizens to live in a clean
environment we're asking all those in
power to resign and be held accountable
financially all of them we will stay
here until our demands are met
the protesters come from a cross-section
of society and that is what everyone is
telling us is so important in a city
that's been stigmatized due to a past
spillover of the Syrian war when gun
battles were fought out in the streets
the people have come together against
the ruling elite they also want to
change the sectarian system which they
accuse politicians of exploiting in
order to keep people divided but there
seems to be a stalemate now the
government isn't standing down the
people aren't leaving there are
unpredictable times ahead Stephanie
Decker al Jazeera Tripoli